um i want to tell you guys what i did
this week
yay
so
as you guys know i'll be doing these
street interviews
and today i i held up a sign you know
what
i'm in shorts but i'm going to show you
guys the sign because it's right here
hold on hold on okay
no
you didn't the audacity of this [ __ ]
pearl you are trying to get
messed up aren't you like this is what
you're trying to do right we're like
actively concerned for her safety
we're concerned for your safety like you
are no longer safe because these
feminists will cast spells on you like
they're all witches you didn't know that
are they because i had a couple like
tell me if they're gonna do witchcraft
on me this is like a feminist thing a
lot yes they do the people in the pagan
stuff right
or um the witchcraft stuff is like the
number one um
religion that's popping up with
feminists and like the
lgbtqia plus minus sign divided by like
all that stuff the alphabet crew that's
their number one that in satanism so
like you combine the two it's like
you're gonna pearl i'm really concerned
for you should probably hire like body
cards at this point because if you're
going to be like a steven crowder out
there like you can't
be by yourself okay okay so let's let's
let's let's talk about these claims
one i don't believe in witchcraft so
they can't witchcraft me if i don't
believe in it facts facts so go ahead
witchcraft me i don't know what that
means like
oh
second off second off i did hire a
bodyguard this time
good i did i did hire about it was some
random guy off of instagram so hopefully
that goes well
peterson of you
perfect
they said
well peter i didn't know i didn't i
didn't know where to find a bodyguard
someone just messaged me and was like
i'm a bodyguard i'm like okay and the
dog
you know 18 body fat what is it like six
foot two no we'll do six but right now
look at he was doing good he was doing
good
no no i meant like why get a bodyguard
when he could just get a man
i like the way you think yeah slide into
my dms yeah be her bodyguard and hiding
she's gonna hidey clown that okay
no okay so i was out i was out with that
that sign right had my bodyguard had my
cameraman came too so i wasn't like by
myself right
and this man comes up
and i always said i said abortion is a
cop-out and he's like well what about in
the cases of grape i'm like
we're talking about we're talking about
the rule not exceptions
and this man keeps arguing with me he's
like 98 condoms are 98 effective that's
2
your rule is less than 1
and he keeps going back and forth with
me
and i'm just like okay
sir sir and he kept he kept interrupting
me i'm like sir sir this is my platform
i can argue what i want to argue
if you want to go argue you're two
percent you can go build your own
channel like
i'm gonna have to talk to the next
person but i'm like the audacity these
people come and i'm like i should you
should pay me to argue with you that's
how i feel about it
and i'm like they come up to me and they
have the audacity of telling me what i
need to talk about on my show
yeah
go make your own show
that's what i've been saying that's what
i've been saying on tick tock so now i'm
like trying this my hand at tick tock
for some reason i don't know why
um but
they get mad at me for speaking on my
own platform i'm like if you are that
upset about it all you gotta do is
scroll up that's all you gotta do right
or just walk away from the conversation
but no they want to literally like they
get so upset
and they're the ones that are making
them upset you didn't do anything
they're getting all up in arms because
like god forbid you have a different
opinion than them and
like
you want to share that on your platform
which you're paying for
you paid for the bodyguard you paid for
the camera man you are sponsoring the
show if they want to do it then they can
pay you to be on the show just like
everyone else does when they like try to
go on these uh celebrity tv shows
like
shut up if you don't if you
okay if
if you are upset about it just
walk away it's really simple it's not
that difficult and i think we've lost
that as a society um
so that's my
that's my two cents on that well i feel
bad for saying this right but people are
doing this vr stuff right
and like women of all ages are getting
virtually graped and i'm just like
take it off your dang head like just
throw it like what come on
come on
and everything and i'm so sorry but okay
i'm just gonna say this
not everything is grape
if you if you literally
slept with someone and then you felt bad
about it that doesn't mean that it was
great and so i just need to say that for
the women because
y'all are saying that everything is
great
and if it was why didn't you report it
to the cops and why didn't you go to the
hospital and why didn't you get the pill
so that you could take care of that
possible
um i don't know if i can say the a word
on here but
why don't you do that no because you
actually are just
dealing with the emotions of the fact
that you didn't want to sleep with that
person and then you consented to it
because you were drunk and they were
drunk and then now y'all got to deal
with it so no not everything is great
not everything is essay and you need to
just understand that
maybe you made a bad decision and maybe
you gotta deal with it
and okay if i get drunk and i rob a
store did i not rob the store
did you not drink and drive right you
got in the car you drank and drive you
got in the car you got the dui
so like that's the same thing
you can't you can't blame it on the fact
that you were drunk
like oh my gosh
have you noticed that women have an
excuse for everything so when i'm here i
have this sign i have this sign right
and i'm like i'm going around i'm saying
look i think abortion's a cop-out in
most cases outside of grape i think
abortions cop out because it's and they
said they say why right and i said
because you're you're asking you're
bailing being bailed out for your poor
decisions and they'll always argue with
me they'll be like well was it a poor
decision i'm like was it a good decision
[Music]
the arguments end really quickly
whenever pearl's like
why are you sleeping with men that you
don't think would be a good father i
guess
it gets posed they're like you know what
checkmate man check me
or hear me out
and they'll be like well
my body's bad on birth control we'll get
an iud
well i mean we're in cycle tracking i
don't know abstinence i don't
no no there's there's there's way
i want it to be perfect what do you mean
you want to